Narrator: From wading in the 9/11
Memorial pools
in New York City
and removing dangerous rocks
halfway up the Niagara Falls cliffs,
to sanitizing the train cars of Tokyo's
renowned metro system,
here's everything we deep cleaned in 2023.
Narrator: This is Jim.
He's cleaning the reflecting pools
at the 9/11 Memorial in New York City.
Jim and his team are working beneath
a 27-foot-tall waterfall
in near-total darkness,
vacuuming every inch of the pool.
Their goal is to do it
without missing a spot.
It's a physically demanding job,
but that's not the only challenge.
Jim: I've never actually
marked how many miles it is,
but you do a few miles in there,
and it could be humid,
and you come out of there
and you feel like you
walked on the moon, almost.
Narrator: The pools are
nearly an acre each,
so it will take hours to finish the job
before the sun comes up.
While he works inside the pool,
other crew members work on
the bronze panels aboveground.
These routines happen five
days a week and are essential
for keeping the memorial
in pristine condition
for the millions who come
to pay their respects here.
They start by shutting off the waterfalls,
and over the next eight hours,
Jim and his team work tirelessly
to deep clean this pool.
Jim: The hardest part is it's a long task.
The pool is big. It's not a swimming pool.
It's a 200-by-200 giant pool.
I'm going to pull the hose
out and then bring it back.
Rian: Gotcha.
Jim: You don't have to use the whole reel.
We got too much hose.
We usually have three
men through the pool,
so two guys will be in the pool
and one guy will be
outside running the pumps,
which collect the debris
and return the clean
water back to the pool.
Once we're set, we're on our way.
I go and vacuum, generally,
and whoever's with me
that night brushes behind.
Come on, hurry up.
Rian: Sorry.
Jim: We don't got all day here.
The vacuum will capture
most of the debris,
and the person brushing will knock up
some of the other loose debris
that doesn't get caught,
and it will be caught
into some of our filters
that we have running downstairs.
Now I'm trapped in the hose here.
I'm going to trip myself.
And we'll be on "America's Bloopers."
Narrator: The workers generally
clean out dirt, leaves,
and algae from the bottom of the pools.
They also remove larger items
that visitors drop or throw in.
They don't always know
what they'll encounter
in the pool each night.
Jim: We find kids' toys,
little small items.
Depends on the crowd.
One night I actually found a bat in there.
And I'm not talking about a baseball bat,
I'm talking about a bat.
It was pretty wild when
he flew away from me
when I realized I was grabbing a bat.
Depending on the cleanliness of the pool,
it could take anywhere between
six and seven hours.
And sometimes, if we feel up to it,
we could do it a little quicker.
Some people treat this
place like a wishing well.
So we do catch some money,
and unfortunately I think some people,
being that it's so far removed
from the original 9/11,
I think some people are a little
uneducated about this place,
and some people treat it
like just a regular fountain,
and they're throwing garbage
in here sometimes too.
People have to learn that
this isn't your mall fountain.
I knew a few of the
brokers that passed away,
a whole group of them who had a meeting
in one of the towers, unfortunately, and,
except for one trader,
all of them perished.
I think about them often
because we go up top where the names are
and brush near the
nameplates, the troughs,
and on the north side,
they're all on one panel.
So I see their names just about every day.
Total waste of lives
that could have been doing
good in the world now.
Narrator: While Jim and the team
finish cleaning the pools below,
Ryan is tackling the
bronze name panels above.
The panels honor the 2,983
victims of the attacks
on the World Trade Center,
both in 1993 and 2001.
Ryan will have to strip
the top layer of metal
and use a blowtorch to remove a carving
someone etched onto the plaque,
without damaging the rest of the memorial.
Ryan: Confuses me why you'd
want to write something here.
For a mark like that,
you have to go pretty
deep, get all the way down.
Otherwise you can't really get rid of it.
If you don't go down far enough,
you'll see it when you refinish it.
The further down you go, the better.
Sometimes I've seen nice things written,
but, you know, they don't understand.
You can't just write
whatever you want on it.
Narrator: After briefly
assessing the damage,
Ryan needs to remove the protective bars
so he can reach the entire metal surface.
To do this, he props up
the bars with a wood plank
and unhooks the brackets
holding up the panels.
Ryan: Whew!
Now what I'll do is rub
it down with the naphtha.
It's almost like a paint thinner.
It just kind of takes the wax
off, so I'm not burning wax.
If I can open it.
And it shouldn't take too long
once I get the torch on it.
There's so much in the prep,
and then the finishing,
the torch is actually not that bad.
Narrator: After sanding
down the top layer of panel
and neutralizing the wax,
Ryan is ready to
blowtorch the damaged area
to melt the metal in the patina
so he can repaint the color layer
and restore the panel
to its original state.
Ryan: This is what we use,
and it's basically just
a patina in a solution.
Ah, I haven't used you in a while.
Prep them.
So, I'm basically getting
up to the right temperature.
If it's too cold, it'll go on spotty.
If it's too hot, it'll
kind of evaporate off
or it'll get burnt.
Narrator: In the summer months,
the longest part of the job
is waiting for the burned panel to cool
before applying a new layer
of wax and an acrylic topcoat
to finish the restoration process.
We're going to put the
acrylic spray on it,
just kind of like a clear coat.
It helps it kind of adhere
a little bit better.
The last step, really. Well,
besides buffing the wax off.
So I'm just going to put
the wax on real nice.
Not too hard, not a lot.
You don't need a ton.
Just put it on lightly.
The wax will go over the
finish and make it look,
once I polish it, it'll look brand new.
We got a little bit of heat,
but that's because it's still hot.
But it was right here.
Narrator: Now all Ryan has to
do is buff off the excess wax
using a white Scotch-Brite pad.
Ryan: And then once it gets
smooth, you know you're done.
When people do something like that,
I wouldn't say it makes
me angry. I get it.
Some of these people might
not have even been alive
when it happened, or they
were too young to get it.
My uncle was a New York City firefighter,
and he was hurt really bad here,
but luckily he survived.
We got a little lucky.
Narrator: After a strenuous
six to seven hours of cleaning,
Jim and the team are ready
to head out of the pool.
By tomorrow morning, a
new batch of visitors
will see sparkling pools
below rushing waterfalls,
and most of them won't know
that Jim's team was even here.
Jim: When we finish the
pool, most of the time,
we're just ready to
really get out of there.
And most of our inspection,
we're fairly confident
that we did the proper job.
There's always a little fail factor,
but not too bad.
My father worked in these
buildings almost his whole life.
And my father was here
for the '93 bombing,
and that was before
cellphones and everything,
and he was on the 30th
floor of the second tower.
When he was there, he
was the floor marshal.
He came home full of
soot, but he stayed there
because there was people that
couldn't get down the steps.
So he made sure that he stayed with them.
So I think on 9/11 day, if he was here,
we probably would've lost him
because he wouldn't have left.
He passed away a couple years ago.
He was always so proud of the job.
I probably had chances to do
other things in this building,
but even if I wanted to do another job,
I wouldn't, because of him.
And now, I love doing it, so I do it.
Narrator: Next up, we travel to Japan
to see how the Tokyo Metro keeps its reputation
as one of the cleanest transportation
systems in the world.
Narrator: This is Takayuki,
a cleaning supervisor at
the rail yard in Ayase.
He's worked for Tokyo
Metro for almost 41 years,
and it's his job to make sure
the trains are cleaned thoroughly.
Narrator: The Tokyo Metro system is famous
for being one of the cleanest
subway systems in the world.
It transports an average of
about 6 million people daily,
and maintaining that reputation
takes both an extensive amount
of operational organization
and a ton of manpower.
The cleaning staff's
approach is straightforward
but uncompromising: whatever Tokyo Metro's
millions of daily passengers
touch must be cleaned.
Today, they're cleaning the train cars
at the Ayase rail yard,
which they do every 15 days.
The cleaners take careful measures
to ensure each nook and cranny is cleaned.
Then we'll head to the
Ginza-itchome Station,
located in one of the
busiest shopping areas
in Tokyo, Japan,
where they clean the
station top to bottom.
There are 41 trains on the
Tokyo Metro Chiyoda Line.
The team cleans three
to four trains a day.
Once a train comes into the rail yard,
cleaners start by picking
up any trash they see.
It takes four workers
to clean the exterior.
It's all done by hand, and cleaners start
by hosing it down with water
and then using brushes
to scrub it with soap.
Narrator: If the stain does not come off
with a brush and soap,
then they use a pad to scrub it off.
Next, they rinse off all the soap.
Meanwhile, other staffers
clean the interior.
It takes 10 workers, and they
start at the top of the car
and work their way down to the bottom.
Narrator: The first step
is to clean the area
where advertisements are placed.
Then they clean the luggage
racks, and then the wall area.
They use rags and dusters
to clean each part.
Narrator: Cleaners then tackle the floors
and start by mopping.
They also use sticks to clean crevices
near the entrance of each door.
Twice a year they wax the
floors of each train car.
They remove all the old
wax with a polisher,
and then they let it dry.
Once it's dry, they
apply two coats of wax.
It takes about an hour and a half
from the time the wax is removed
to the time the new wax dries.
Narrator: Altogether, it takes workers
a little over an hour
to clean the trains inside and out.
Once the cleaning is complete,
Takayuki begins his inspection.
Narrator: Once Takayuki
approves the cleaning,
the trains return to service,
ready to transport millions
of passengers all over again.
Inside the Ginza-itchome Station,
Chikako and Kenji work to
clean the station daily.
Narrator: Kazuhiro has been
working for Tokyo Metro
since he was 18.
He got his train license at 20
and drove trains until he was 57.
He leads the team responsible
for the cleaning and security
for this station and a few others.
There are nine Tokyo Metro train lines
and 180 stations that provide service
to the greater Tokyo area.
Narrator: The escalator handrails
are a high-touch surface
within the station,
and Chikako takes extra
care to wipe the belt
with wet washcloths.
She rides the escalators up and down
until they are all clean.
Narrator: Chikako is also responsible
for the dirtiest job of the day,
cleaning the two restrooms
in the Ginza-itchome Station.
The main cleanings happen once a day.
She has been doing this
work for the past 10 years.
Narrator: The first thing Chikako does
is check for any large pieces of trash.
If there are none, she sets up a fan
and leaves it on throughout
the cleaning process.
Efficiency is one of the
key parts of her job,
and the fan allows the
bathroom to dry quickly,
so as not to disrupt any
customers who may need to use it.
Narrator: Chikako sticks
the ozone-machine hose
down the toilet and turns it on.
Then she scrubs each toilet by hand
to make sure it's clean
for the next customer.
She also cleans the walls.
It's important that she's
using the right tools
for each space, so as not
to cross-contaminate areas.
She uses a red dust cloth to clean
areas from the knees down,
which is called the "contamination zone,"
and a green one for "clean zones,"
which are areas above the knees,
such as mirrors and sinks.
Narrator: Chikako is also
responsible for cleaning
the barrier between the
platform and the train doors.
The top part is cleaned daily,
while the lower part
is cleaned once a week.
The staff makes sure the
station platforms and walkways
are clean for customers.
They do cleanings with brooms every day,
but they also use a
machine to clean the floors
twice a month.
The machine works by sprinkling
water onto the floor,
scrubbing with a brush,
and then collecting the
dirty water with a squeegee.
This way, there is no water left behind
and no slippery floors.
Narrator: Kenji also goes around daily
with a shoulder vacuum
and manually vacuums up
any trash and dust he comes across,
especially in hard-to-reach areas.
Narrator: Japan has a
long history with cleaning
and cleanliness that persists today.
Narrator: This is Rivers.
He's wading through a pool
of waste beneath one of
the largest aquariums in
the world, Georgia Aquarium.
It's a filthy job, but that's
not the only challenge.
There's a lot of waste to manage.
When this basin is full,
it can hold between 5,000
to 10,000 gallons of poop
that funnels here from
the aquarium's habitats.
And it's the culmination of
many routine cleaning procedures
that happen at the aquarium each week,
without which the safety
and health of the
animals would be at risk.
By the time Rivers and his
team's work here is complete,
the wastewater from this basin
will be cleaned, filtered,
and reused as top-off water
for the aquarium's largest
exhibit, Ocean Voyager,
and the cleaning cycle will begin again.
But before Rivers can do his job,
several other critical
procedures have to happen first.
Every day, specialized teams gear up
to clean the hundreds of
exhibits at the aquarium.
One of the first you'll see
when you enter the aquarium
is the sea lion exhibit,
which is home to this guy,
Toby, a 279-pound harbor seal.
Before a team of divers can
begin cleaning his habitat,
Toby and the other sea lions
need to vacate their pools.
Staffers use this time to
do their weekly weigh-ins.
Trainer: And if we're
talking about dirty jobs,
he just urinated on the scale,
and now we've got to clean it.
Side effect of the job.
Alex: This pool, it's all sea lion poop.
It's all sea lion poop.
Everything that she's vacuuming from here
is going into that waste basin.
So whatever we do in here,
the LSS, or life-support team,
then has to clean up from their end.
Narrator: Megan Wade
leads the pinnipeds team
to clean the decks and assist
the dive operations team
as they clean the pools
before guests arrive.
This space is home to 14 sea
lions and three harbor seals.
The sea lions can eat 5%
to 8% of their body weight,
making the sea lion exhibit
one of the dirtiest in the aquarium.
Megan: Every single morning
we come in first thing
and prepare their food, and
this is restaurant-quality fish.
So they get numerous species of fish,
about five different species.
And every single morning,
one or two people
will come in and inspect
every single fish.
So we're looking for missing eyes,
missing fins, gills, scrapes, cuts.
Anywhere where you're going to
see that can breed bacteria.
So that fish automatically
gets sorted out,
and we don't use it at all.
We weigh out their food into buckets.
And then we'll look at it again
one last time before
feeding it to the animals.
Once a week, every Wednesday,
it's weigh-day Wednesday.
Follow me this way.
We have our blue scale right here.
And then where the green is lit up
is going to tell us how much they weigh.
So each sea lion will walk
from their habitat down this hallway.
We'll get their weight,
and then they'll walk
back to their habitat.
Narrator: After the sea lions are fed,
weighed, and out of the main spaces,
Megan and the team start working
on cleaning the deck areas.
Her team splits up between the back pools
and the main gallery,
where they detail every nook and cranny.
As soon as you come in in the morning,
you can usually smell
that they have been sleeping overnight.
We have high-up platforms
that they like to sleep on, the rocks.
And when you're sleeping,
and you don't get up
to go to the bathroom,
it all just sits there.
So if we didn't clean every single day,
it would be really stinky,
kind of an ammonia smell.
Also, there's fecal matter as well.
We are going to detail this whole area.
It gets cleaned every single day,
but we detail it once a week, every week.
Three male sea lions
and one male harbor seal
all slept out here last night.
So it's probably going to be pretty messy.
The chemicals that we use
are to really break up
that oil that's on the surface
that the sea lions secrete.
So it's just soap and water.
And then we'll use some chlorhexidine
to disinfect the area afterwards.
And then down here, Gail has
like a nice little hand brush,
and she's actually doing
one of the dirtiest jobs.
She's cleaning the drains.
All of this is going to
always be hosed to a drain
away from the water the sea lions swim in.
She's taking the grates off,
cleaning inside the drain,
so that everything flows
nicely each day that we clean.
So the drains are part of the detailing.
The removal of the net
and soaking, that's part of the detailing.
Sea lions, when they breathe,
sometimes shoot snot out of their nose.
So a lot of times in sea lion habitats,
you'll see brown snot on the walls.
So we'll need to scrub that off, too.
My favorite part about cleaning the deck
is getting to net the
poop out of the water,
because it's just so reinforcing
when you do a good job
and you get good at it.
So I just love doing it.
Narrator: After Megan
and the pinnipeds team
work on the main gallery deck,
Alex Glick and a team of divers
work on everything below
deck at the sea lion exhibit.
Alex: Today you're going
to start in pool two
and then do pool three.
This one's vacuuming and floor-scrubbing.
And then pool three, you'll
be vacuuming rockwork
and then a final floor scrub.
So we do this dive on just normal scuba.
Even though it's only an 8-foot pool,
we still do scuba diving
so that you have freedom of movement.
This is our vacuum hose.
They actually plug this in in the water,
and we have to make a radio
call to our life support system,
and they'll turn the vacuum on.
So we drop the vacuum head in the water
with the hose attached to the diver.
And then they'll prime the hose
to get all of the air out of the line.
This pool, it's all sea lion poop.
You want to get as much vacuumed up
before you start scrubbing the floor.
Narrator: This scrubber is one of
the key tools the divers use
to thoroughly clean
everything under the water.
A hose pumps water through the engine,
which powers the scrubber.
This high-pressure water
makes cleaning the floors
and walls much easier.
The single scrubber has hard bristles
and is used for rockwork,
while the double-brush scrubber
is used to clean the walls
and painted surfaces.
Alex: Once she's done vacuuming,
I'll give this to her,
and she will then clean the floor.
And she's holding the trigger down,
and she's just swimming back and forth,
doing kind of like a lawnmower motion,
cleaning one side to the next
to get every single inch of the pool.
If she comes across an area
that's particularly dirty,
she might slow down and
spend a little time on it
to get up whatever scum is on
the bottom and then move on.
Narrator: Animal debris
doesn't just settle
on the habitat's floors and surfaces.
It also collects in
grates and skimmer boxes.
These outflows help manage
waste between routine cleanings
by separating animals
from some of the debris.
In total, it takes Alex
and his team of divers
roughly an hour to complete
their work in both pools.
On the other side of the
aquarium is Ocean Voyager,
the largest indoor aquatic
exhibit in the United States.
It holds 6.3 million gallons of water
and is home to whale sharks, manta rays,
and thousands of other fish.
This space is largely dependent
on an advanced life-support
and filtration system
but still relies on teams
for maintenance and hands-on cleaning.
Courtney: In Ocean Voyager,
we have two whale sharks.
There's Yushan, which is
the larger whale shark,
and then there's Taroko.
Common misconception about whale sharks
would be that they're dangerous.
The most intimidating
thing is they're just big.
They just are big.
And so if you're in the way,
you've just got to move.
They are not out to hurt you.
Like, their throat is only
a the size of a quarter.
They're very, very docile creatures,
and they just want to cruise along.
We usually have four to eight divers
in our everyday maintenance dive.
We clean the windows, so
we need our suction cup.
We bring what we call a diaper.
Otherwise it just looks like a rag.
And we clean the acrylic
windows with that.
And then usually we're
doing hand-scrubbing.
They are scrubbing off the algae.
And they're kind of basically wafting off
all that sand substrate that cakes on
and falls over onto those rocks.
All that stuff that can grow on there
is potentially harmful for all the fish.
So the whole goal of cleaning,
upkeeping the exhibit,
isn't necessarily to keep it pretty,
even though that is also very beneficial,
to keep it pretty for the guests.
But at the same time, there is the purpose
of doing it for the health of the exhibit.
This is a monster exhibit.
So if if we didn't do it every day,
it'd be pretty much impossible to upkeep.
The blitz dives, which
are our night dives,
that's our essential deep clean.
So it can be a couple hours long,
just to get everything we can done.
We can run up to four
of those Armada machines
and clean different areas of the exhibit.
Narrator: While Ocean
Voyager is being cleaned,
Carolyn Murphy and the aquarist team
are over at the River Scout gallery
getting ready to dive into
these three freshwater tanks.
The smallest tanks measure
4 feet tall by 3 feet deep,
and the team spends one
to two hours every week
cleaning the windows
and maintaining the
underwater gardens here.
Carolyn: So despite the
size of these tanks,
we actually do manage to
squeeze some people in there.
What we are going to be doing is
something called hookah diving.
So the divers are getting
in very carefully.
They're kind of sliding
in the top of the tank.
And they're going to be
holding themselves up
in the water column by pressing their feet
to opposite sides of the tank,
or putting them on the
outside the top rim.
And they'll kind of hold
themselves with their core strength
kind of up in the water column
to do the work they need to do.
So we're focusing on the algae
that's growing on the
window and the plant leaves,
and then also the detritus
that's building up in the tanks.
And that can be fecals
from fish or leftover food.
Narrator: The team goes into the dive
with a few core tools: a
scrub brush, trimming tools,
and a fine plastic scraper to
clean algae off the windows.
The most painstaking part for
the aquarists in this tank
is cleaning out the beard algae.
Carolyn: So it is so
annoying, and it is something
that we tediously try
to keep under control.
So you're seeing these
little kind of black puffs.
And that's what she's targeting right now
when she's scraping it off,
and immediately removing
it from the system,
because it will just
spread over everything.
Narrator: The divers use a gravity siphon
to clean out the loose debris
that's settled in the gravel.
This isn't powered by electricity.
It relies solely on gravity to suction up
and separate the waste from the gravel.
Carolyn: Algae covering
everything doesn't look great.
But it also can cause
problems for your fish.
So algae blooms in the wild
can kind of take the oxygen
that the fish need out of the system.
So it can cause some
harm for them that way.
Narrator: All the waste and debris
from each of these cleanings ends up here.
This is cleaned out every
three to four months
to ensure the basin doesn't overflow,
it doesn't create water-quality issues,
and all the systems
continue to run smoothly.
Rivers: As you can see,
we've got just piles of poop
and debris and extra food,
stuff that didn't get digested properly,
stuff that didn't get eaten,
got pulled into filtration.
Most of it is just animal waste.
There is a little bit of sand,
probably about 10 5-gallon buckets or so.
The equipment we'll use to clean the basin
is a fire hose and a snow shovel.
Narrator: Cleaning this space
takes roughly two to three
hours and is done in stages.
They'll remove the poop, clean the floors,
and then shovel all the sand out.
Once we've gotten the sand out,
then we'll go around
and inspect the walls,
make sure there's no cracks,
make sure the waterproofing is still good.
So where all the discoloration happens
is about where the basin gets,
roughly 55,000 to 60,000
gallons to a full basin.
But other than being gross,
the hardest part is definitely
getting the sand out,
just because we've got to
lift it 25 feet in the air.
So we really only want to
fill them about half full.
If they were to get too
full, they might splash.
And they're also just really heavy.
Once this basin is full, we will then
recirculate all this water and
clean this water to reuse it
for top-off water for our
Ocean Voyager exhibit.
After the recovery, all
this water is crystal clean.
Narrator: Next, we head to Niagara Falls,
where special teams show us how they remove
dangerous rocks and maintain
the trails for visitors' safety.
Narrator: This jagged sheet of rock
is hanging 200 feet above a walking trail
next to the Niagara River.
It's already loose, and if it falls,
it could mean serious injury
to hikers on the path below.
That's where the rope
access team comes in.
If they do their job just right,
most of Niagara Falls' 9
million yearly visitors
will never even know they were here.
Andy: First jump of the day.
Andy: Am I scared?
Crew member: Yeah.
Andy: Am I scared?!
Crew member: You should be.
Andy: I have a healthy
respect. That's all.
Narrator: This cliff is located
at Devil's Hole State Park,
roughly 4 miles north of Niagara Falls.
Team members like Andy and
Christian will scale the cliff
and maintain the crew's gear.
Later, Jake will clear
dislodged rocks from the trail.
If those rocks were to fall naturally,
there's nothing stopping them from coming
and just plowing through
somebody that's on the trail.
So very necessary work, what we do here,
and you can see here all the rocks
that come down there are pretty sizable,
and they could cause some damage.
Narrator: It's a dangerous job.
Dehydration, injury, and inclement weather
are just some of the risks.
Thunderstorms are forecast today,
so the team is on high alert
for signs of lightning,
which would endanger the crew.
Andy: We won't work in
lightning. That's about it.
We're going to have fun.
You know, usually when
we show this to people,
they say they didn't
even know this existed.
Narrator: There are 12
members of today's crew:
four supervisors, including
Andy, and eight technicians.
Today, their goal is to clear
this entire section of the cliff.
Their day begins at 7 a.m.
at the maintenance shop,
where the team packs a
variety of gear into vehicles
to take it to the access
point above the trail.
Andy: See, the fun thing about this
is that I don't actually
jump with them every day.
So today will be one of
the days I jump with them,
which is good because I've been
wanting to do this for a while.
These are the guys who
do it every single day,
and they're really, really good at it.
Narrator: After a short 10-minute drive,
the team arrives at the access
point and begins gearing up.
Christian: I guess we could start with
the pièce de résistance.
This is our climbing harness.
It's a Class III harness,
and it's called that because
of the shoulder straps.
Narrator: The shoulder
straps prevent climbers
from slipping out of the harness
if they accidentally turn upside down,
and the seat balances their body weight
so that blood flow to their
legs isn't restricted.
Comfort is also of the utmost importance,
as climbers can be suspended
for more than two hours at a time.
Christian: This device
here is our bar rack.
This is what we use to rappel.
It's a pretty old-school device.
We have a lot of mud and grit,
and when the ropes get wet, they swell.
So there's not a lot of moving
parts; it's all friction.
So that's our descent device.
Andy: All right, pretty
much all ready to go here.
No one cares about me.
Everyone says, "Andy, just
take care of yourself."
[laughing]
So, what they're talking about
is some guys have a rope
handler watching their line,
and then some of us are
on what we call an ASAP,
which is this. This is your backup device.
And so I'm just fully in
control of all of my descent.
So I can actually step over the edge now.
First jump of the day.
Andy: Am I scared?
Crew member: Yeah.
Andy: Am I scared?!
Crew member: You should be.
Andy: I have a healthy
respect. That's all.
The crew's really close.
You know, we joke around a lot,
but when it is time to
actually go over the edge
and do work, we kind
of call that game time,
because it is. You know, you
need to take it seriously
because there's a lot of risks involved.
This program that we're a part of
has been going on since about the 1930s,
and about the whole time
they've been using pike poles.
There's a lot of utility with this.
This is made out of solid fiberglass here.
So if it gets into the cliff,
this can flex a lot.
You can use this to position
yourself on the wall,
and then you can use this
to gently remove debris.
You can grab stuff with the
hook, gently pull it out.
It can fit into cracks,
and then you can get leverage that way.
Narrator: One of the things that makes
removing these rocks
especially challenging
is that these cliffs undergo
something called differential erosion,
which means that areas of the cliff erode
at different rates.
Layers of shale rock located
lower on the cliffside
wear away more quickly
than the layer of
dolomite rock at the top.
That leaves large unstable chunks of rock,
sometimes the size of an SUV,
hanging at the cliff's edge.
The crew uses a controlled swing
to gain access to material
beneath overhangs.
To do this, they push
themselves away from the wall
with their feet to maintain
that controlled movement.
These are softball shin pads,
and they work really,
really well for what we do.
You try not to knee the wall,
but sometimes for stability
purposes, you know,
you can't really help it.
We all try to wear steel toe
or some sort of composite toe.
Rocks are hard.
You know, you can't always
dodge a rock when you're moving,
so having something like
that to keep yourself safe
is 100% necessary.
So, all the rocks that we're knocking down
are essentially coming right
to the trail and then some,
and they're going right
to the Niagara River,
which we have right there below us.
Narrator: It's 10 a.m.
The crew is only about
two-thirds of the way through their climb
when the one thing they're
worried about happens: a storm.
[thunder striking]
Crew member: Copy. Looks like
we might have a wall of rain.
Cinematographer: Yeah,
I'm going to head back.
Let's head back.
Narrator: The crew hears
thunder and spots lightning
as they're on the cliffside.
They need to stop working immediately.
That will end their progress for today.
Andy: So, today we
actually had to cut short.
We have metal pike poles in our hand.
We got a lot of metal gear on us,
so we just tried to get out of
there as quickly as we could.
Anything that's going to pose
a hazard to the employees,
then we just stop.
Narrator: The crew had only been working
on the 200-foot cliffside
for less than an hour
when the storm began.
On a typical day, it could
take the crew up to three hours
to clear a whole section.
When they're able to resume,
they'll finish removing rocks
from the lower section of the cliff
and then stabilize the slope
side with wire meshing.
This is the primary part of our work here,
that we're going to try
and clear this all out
so we can essentially have an
open hiking trail here again.
And it's going to take a good bit of work
and a good bit of time
to get this cleared out
to be safe for us to open it again.
Narrator: Back at the shop,
the crew does paperwork
and washes their gear.
Andy: There's actually a
lot of paperwork required
with all this stuff,
and then also just
keeping their gear clean.
You can kind of see from my shirt,
I'm filthy from one jump today.
And, you know, if this is how I look,
our gear is even worse.
Christian: So, soapy water helps
break it and lift the dirt.
Using a toothbrush too to get in there,
and then using an air compressor to spray
any of the soap and dirt that's in there.
And then we have a
lubricant too when it's dry
to get in there, and it
prevents rust and corrosion.
Narrator: After the rope access
team has made some progress,
it's time to start clearing the rocks
from the walking paths below.
This is where the gorge crew comes in.
Jake: We take care of
about seven trails in total
within the gorge itself
and then two up top, on topside.
Now we are in the process
of cleaning the trail
and rebuilding it.
We've already come down,
cleared the loose debris off the trail,
and then started staging to get ready
for the bigger jobs ahead.
Narrator: One of those jobs
includes a specialized
stabilization technique
to ensure the slope side is secure.
Jake: So, down here, to fix these trails,
we use gabion baskets.
It's a 6-foot-by-3-foot cube
that is made of wire meshing.
And what you do is you dig them down,
place them within the trail
or wherever you need them,
and then you add rock to the inside
so that the rock weighs it down.
A job like this can take a week or two,
but if we have a good day
where we're really rocking
and getting stuff done,
it can be a maybe three- to four-day job.
Christian: This mound right
here, if all hands are on deck,
I'd like to see, hopefully
by the end of the summer
we get a majority of it taken out
and then we have put in some
stabilization techniques
to help build the trail back up.
So I could definitely see
us working into the fall,
and if I had to make a guess,
it'll probably be open next summer.
Andy: I think if you're going
to do this kind of work,
at the core, you have to
enjoy working outdoors.
You get to see special
things that people don't see,
plants and animals, the landscape.
The work that you do, it's really hard,
but then you're helping
keep the park safe.
You make a meaningful difference.
If you're just a park user,
you might not even realize
we were ever there,
and that's kind of the point.
Narrator: This is Mack.
He specializes in cleaning
homes of people with hoarding disorder
and is used to wading through
heaping piles of clutter,
but this job presents an
unusually large challenge.
Mack will be cleaning a
six-bedroom home in Illinois,
and it's the biggest he's ever tackled.
This is just a nightmare.
I mean, we're finding food from 2013,
we've got paint cans that I
no longer have the strength to carry.
Narrator: Mack often cleans solo
and does much of this work free of charge,
but this job is so
daunting that he's invited
two other cleaners to join him.
Over the next three days,
they'll work together
to declutter and clean as
many rooms as possible.
Mack: Normally I'm dealing
with a totally different type of cleaning.
In other hoarder houses, I'm dealing
with a lot of insects and
mouse droppings and pet urine
and just a lot of stuff
that you definitely want
to have PPE on in order
to even enter the house.
This one was just piles
upon piles of stuff.
It's the most stuff that I've
ever taken out of a house.
Narrator: This house
belongs to a family of four,
who declined to appear on
camera due to privacy reasons.
One of the family members is believed
to be living with hoarding disorder,
although he's awaiting
an official diagnosis.
But even with treatment,
experts say relapses can occur.
This is the fourth time
cleaners have worked extensively
to declutter this home.
The last attempt was five years ago.
Mack: Rooms in hoarder houses,
we will often find rooms
that have never been entered in a decade.
And one of the reasons that
happens, and it's really common,
is you have a room that
no longer has a purpose.
So in this room, it's the living room,
and the purpose is to
watch TV and to relax.
If a room loses that purpose
because they start piling things up,
then the purpose of the room becomes
this is where we throw all of our stuff.
This place is not what I'd
consider a hazard or a biohazard.
It's a hazard for tripping.
And it's a hazard for fire,
because they've got an
open fireplace in here,
and they've got so much clutter
that it becomes a danger.
Narrator: Hoarding is defined
as "persistent difficulty
discarding or parting with possessions,
regardless of their actual value."
It's estimated that
somewhere between 2 and 4%
of the worldwide population
have hoarding disorder.
It's only day one of
this ambitious project,
but when Mack and his
team arrive at the house,
they discover things already
aren't going as planned.
Mack: So, they have
cleaned a bunch of stuff
before we got here, which
normally I wouldn't like.
I wanted the big mess,
and I wanted to be able
to go through the whole house
and make it pretty myself.
This is, I think, a 30-yard dumpster.
They've filled two of
these already over the top,
and we're getting ready
to fill the third one.
If we had more time,
we would probably fill
10 of these from this house.
So even though I'm a little disappointed,
I'm really thankful that
they did have the help.
Narrator: Mack and his
team plan to start on
what's typically the hardest
room to clean, the kitchen.
They'll need to pay special
attention to this space
to ensure it's sanitary
enough for handling food.
Then they'll move on to the rooms
on the main level of the house
and finally tackle the basement,
which hasn't been entered in three years.
The key tools Mack and his team use
are an emulsifier to cut through grease,
a homemade all-purpose
cleaner, scouring pads,
and razor-blade scrapers.
Barbie: So, when people are asking
why this job takes so long,
because we have to check everything,
like if it's expired or not
or still good, no.
Mack: Let me get you a cleaner.
OK. Nope, a big no for the old pancakes.
Nope.
Beer. We never waste any beer, no.
Mack: Holy crap. That was a lot.
[grunts]
Yeah, that's pushing an easy 200 pounds.
Narrator: Mack says the biggest challenge
of cleaning a house like
this is knowing what to keep
and what to throw away.
Mack: There are a lot
of people who will say,
"You're fine to throw away
absolutely everything,"
but they don't really mean that.
They mean you can throw away the junk,
but you have to decipher
what's junk and what's not.
There's also the urge to throw away
large armfuls of stuff,
and most of the time
there's going to be some stuff
underneath it that's important.
All right, I got one
counter done. I'm done.
Barbie: Beautiful!
Mack: Back to the hotel.
[Barbie laughs]
Narrator: Although cleaning
the home will make it safer
and more livable, it can
be distressing for people
with hoarding disorder to
see their space transformed.
People who hoard tend to
have a deep connection
with their objects, and removing them
can create an experience of loss,
which is one of the major contributors
of hoarding behaviors.
Mack: He's going to come home to a very,
very dramatic change, and it's
going to be a shock to him.
And even though most people will come home
and see the change and think, "Oh, my God,
this is so great, you've
cleaned my house,"
he's probably not going to feel that way.
Narrator: As day one comes to a close,
Mack and the team have
finished most of the kitchen,
which they will continue to
clean for the next two days.
On day two, Barbie and
Bonnie will also tackle
the sunroom and living room
while Mack ventures into the basement.
Mack: I want to go down to that basement
and do as much as I can
on the basement today.
That is going to completely wear me out.
If I can get that out of the way today,
then that means tomorrow we can do things
like the dining room
and get this floor done.
I'm going to attempt to tackle
this area, this whole area.
There's this part of the basement,
there is a room to my left,
and there's a room over here,
and they all look like what's behind me.
This is going to be extremely difficult
because there is a lot of
things that need to be kept.
Narrator: Mack discovers an abundance
of stockpiled food and supplies,
including countless jugs of water,
jars of marinara sauce,
bottles of hydrogen peroxide,
and 5-gallon containers
filled with something unusual.
All these five gallon buckets,
those are all filled with food.
Yeah, I thought they were paint.
Barbie: What kind?
Mack: That one says macaroni
and spaghetti or something.
So I'm just going to
stack them all together,
and they want to keep them.
Barbie: But do you think it's still good?
Mack: Probably not.
Narrator: People can
inherit characteristics
from their parents that
make them more likely
to develop hoarding behaviors.
Grief and loss can also
contribute to this.
Over the years, Mack has noticed patterns
in the kinds of items
he finds while cleaning.
Mack: They stack up air
filters and medication
and antibiotics and hydrogen
peroxide and alcohol,
and all of them are unopened,
and all of them are there
just in case, and they just
keep building and building.
Narrator: As Mack continues sorting
through jugs of water
and medical supplies,
he stumbles on one item in particular
he's learned to never throw away.
I've thrown away shells
twice, and in both occasions,
people were like, "Have you
seen a big bag of shells?
That was from when we went
to Myrtle Beach or Florida
or whatever on a family trip."
But they're never
displayed as a collection,
they're just stuffed in a
bag in some random spot.
But I've learned over time that shells
are always a memento for somebody.
Unless they've got their
house infested by clams,
in which case they're good to go.
Narrator: Much of what
Mack finds in the basement
needs to be lugged
upstairs to the dumpsters,
and so many trips up and down
the stairs with heavy bags
is starting to take its toll.
Mack: Right now my neck is just throbbing,
and my right arm I'm
pretty sure is injured.
I have to be super careful
today on what I lift
and how I lift it and how much I lift.
It's a little scary because
if I tweak my back any more,
I'm out of the picture, and
I don't want that to happen.
Narrator: Back upstairs, Barbie and Bonnie
are finishing the kitchen
and starting on the living
room and the sunroom.
Bonnie: I wish I had time
to clean all of this,
but, priorities.
Mack: The owner used to
sit out in the sunroom
every morning and have scrambled
eggs and toast and coffee.
She likes to bead.
And I like knowing those
details about the owner
because it lets us know where emotionally
this cleanup is going to
affect them in a positive way.
Narrator: As the crew begins
to wrap up for the day,
the wife of the person
suspected to be living
with hoarding disorder becomes emotional
at the sight of the progress they've made.
Mack: She was on the
second floor of the house
looking over the banister,
and just seeing what
Barbie had accomplished,
and she wasn't even
fully done with the room,
she broke down in tears
just being able to see the floor again.
So if your partner has hoarding disorder,
there is a resentment and
a frustration and an anger
that builds up, and then
finally there's a release point
where everything just comes out.
And that's what happened there.
She is very happy to see it opened up.
She's been in the house for 13 years.
Today's work was way more
exhausting than yesterday.
It's a different type of cleaning, though,
because it takes less of
your mind to do it, I guess.
I'm not really looking
at having to sanitize
and to get out tiny little stains.
I'm just looking to get
things out of people's way.
And so it takes less mental effort,
but, man, it takes a lot
more physical effort.
Narrator: It's the final day of the crew's
three-day cleanup, and
this is their last chance
to organize and declutter
as much of the main floor as possible.
Mack: This is the day where we have to be
basically on our game and moving quickly.
We're wrapping up the kitchen.
We have a dining room which is just stuff
that needs to be moved.
Narrator: Despite the
exhaustion Mack is experiencing,
he returns to the basement
and makes another discovery.
Whew, God.
It's, like, old rotten garden seeds,
and they're not dangerous,
but they smell really bad.
Garden seeds, when they go
bad, smell like raw sewage.
You have to breathe through your mouth
when you're putting it in,
otherwise it'll make you nauseous.
You'll be able to see the story unfold
as you go through layer
after layer of old stuff.
The deeper you go into a hoard,
that's where you start finding
the really rotten stuff.
And so it always gets worse
before it gets better.
Narrator: Excessive acquisition occurs
in the vast majority of cases.
Oftentimes these items are on sale,
and therefore are bought in large amounts.
Mack: So instead of just getting one,
they see the deal and they'll get 20.
But even in a big house like this,
there's not room to put them all.
So you've got this giant
pile of shop lights,
and you're probably going
to find that with everything
from craft supplies to
just random kind of stuff.
Nightlights.
There's an entire rack of nightlights.
What's really frustrating about this
is there's so much stuff that's necessary
and has legitimate, actual use.
That's actually really
rare for a hoarder house.
Narrator: At the end of day three,
the crew has successfully
cleaned the kitchen,
sunroom, living room,
dining room, and basement,
and they've removed enough stuff
to fill three 30-yard
dumpsters to the brim.
Mack: We're almost done now.
Compared to other hoarder
houses that's just me,
with three of us working here,
in order to get the entire
house, every single room,
top to bottom, cleaned, we
would have needed a crew
of probably 10-plus people
for at least two weeks.
Narrator: After Mack and his team leave,
the family will finish
cleaning the remaining rooms.
They'll also hire help
to maintain the home.
Mack: I like seeing a house
that is so covered up with stuff
that whenever you get all of
it put away and where it goes
and you get everything cleaned up,
seeing the house as it
was intended to be seen
is really a cool thing to me,
and I think that's part of my brain
that thinks of rooms like jigsaw puzzles.
What keeps me doing it, I think,
is more the stress relief
that you see happen
on the owner of the house.
You can see the stress come off of them
at the very end whenever you leave.
This one was just
exhausting in every measure
just because of the sheer amount of stuff.
But it's worth it,
especially whenever we get
to look around the house and say,
"Holy crap, we did that. We all did that."
Narrator : Now, we travel to the UK,
where Oli Pickles, the owner of iDoctor,
shows us how he cleans the dirtiest iPhones.
I think the most difficult
part of cleaning an iPhone
is just knowing that you're touching
somebody else's grime and muck.
It's disgusting, really,
when you think about it.
I can already see that we've
got quite a lot of gunk
in the ear speaker and the
speaker grilles themselves,
so hopefully there'll be
some gunk in there to see
and we can give it a real
good clean-out as well.
Lint builds up from
inside somebody's pocket,
and over time, when the
charging cable's inserted,
taken out, reinserted, all that happens
is it just compacts into
the charge port itself
and leaves this sort of mess behind
and all this lint.
Over time, it just compacts.
Every time you put it on charge,
it just compacts deep down into the port.
When you start noticing the
ear speaker becomes quiet,
the microphone, people can't hear you,
or it's not charging correctly,
you might have to stand on your head
and do a backflip just to make it charge,
that's probably when you
need to start thinking
about cleaning out that charge
port or the ear speaker.
I'm using this little BGA scraper,
which is typically designed
for scraping the resin overfill
or underfill from logic boards,
but it doubles up as a
really, really useful tool
for cleaning out these charging ports.
The stuff, what we usually
find in the charging ports
and crevices of the phone,
is mostly either pocket gunk
or fluff from the bottom of handbags.
I mean, I'm not a forensic scientist,
but I'm going to guess there's dog hairs,
dust, fluff.
I don't really know
how to describe the ...
the fibers what are in there.
Other things that we've
found in the phones,
rice is quite common when phones
have become water damaged,
because they'll stick the phone in rice.
That doesn't work, by the way.
We did find some weed in one of them,
and it looked like they must
have been keeping the stash
in the pocket, and it,
the same thing again.
There was weed inside the charge port.
So, this iPhone 7 has come
in for a battery replacement,
and as you can see,
it's absolutely full of dust,
lint, hair, wood chip, feathers;
you name it, it's in this phone.
Well, I can see that the
screen's been replaced before.
I think they've probably
just never replaced
the dust seal what's on there.
This is really common
because, believe it or not,
not many repair places will replace
that dust and moisture seal.
The best way to clean
something like this out
is to get all the thick stuff,
probably with the dust blower.
There is definitely a risk
that this dust could cause a short circuit
on the motherboard.
It's going to put lots of strain
on peripheral hardware
like the loudspeaker.
It's going to be quiet.
The vibration motor's not
going to work very well,
or you're going to get funny sounds
from the vibration motor.
A lot of people think that
it's just for moisture.
It keeps a seal between the screen
and the chassis of the phone,
which, out of the factory, is designed
so that it's sealed away from
elements like dust and dirt.
Ear-speaker cleaning is one of the things
what we get all the time
where somebody's phone's really quiet.
10 to 20% of the phones what we get in
actually need cleaning out.
The easiest way to clean
out an iPhone ear speaker
is using some isopropyl alcohol.
The customer will ask for
a ear-speaker replacing,
but in reality, it just
needs cleaning out.
And even if we did
replace the ear speaker,
it probably would still be quiet
because that mesh is just
bunged up and gunked up.
Then we loosen up the
gunk with a toothbrush.
Make sure that it's not the toothbrush
that you've used this
morning to brush your teeth.
And then we play this sound,
which plays a 165-hertz sound,
[sound humming]
which acts as a sort of
ultrasonic cleaner.
For the most part, I think
that the most common thing
that gets in ear speaker
is probably earwax.
I don't really want to think
about what else it could be,
what's getting in there,
because it's, yeah, it's gross.
We use two different types of brushes.
For the softer brush we use a toothbrush,
and then a slightly more stiff one
is this small horsehair brush.
The vibrations act as an agitator,
and it loosens the dirt,
what's in those tiny little
gaps in the ear speaker.
So, the cloth over the speaker,
we add a little bit of alcohol onto there.
And the way that that works
is just adding a finer
layer of cleaning stuff
just to get any remaining
bits of dust out of there.
So, for this one, it's a iPhone 11 Pro,
and it's got a little bit of
gunk in the speaker grille
at the bottom, which would
make the phone pretty quiet.
This is very similar
to what gets built up
inside the charge port.
It's just pocket gunk.
The best tool for this one
is the sharp, pointed BGA scraper again.
The debris in these holes
will often look like
a browny, sort of beige color,
whereas the actual speakers are black,
so you'll know that
you've got it in there.
I sort of got involved
with fixing friends' and family's phones,
sorting out technical problems for them,
and once I started learning
about phone repair,
I just got deeper and deeper into it.
It's like a rabbit hole,
and I just got fully sucked down it.
We receive about 20 iPhones
per week in the post,
and we probably take in
from walk-in customers between
five and 15 phones a day.
You get lots of instances where somebody
might bring a phone in, and
it might be a minor thing,
and they say, "Oh, look, my
phone's completely dead."
And it's really good to
see people very happy
once you've repaired their devices.
Narrator: Back in the US,
Trae Zipperer shows us how to properly clean
forgotten veteran's gravestones
covered with moss and algae.
So, I get a lot of questions about,
"Why are these stones so dirty?"
This is not dirt. These
are living organisms.
These are plants.
The more polished the stone,
the less surface area there is
for the biological organisms
to adhere to the stone.
And so the reason why we use
this quaternary ammonium
compound is this kills them.
So, these things are natural in nature.
You're going to find in
the South especially,
it's not just growing on rooftops,
it's also growing on our headstones.
My name is Trae Zipperer.
I'm the founder of By Memorial Day,
a nonprofit organization
dedicated to the cleaning
of all veteran headstones by
Memorial Day in perpetuity.
So, this is a ground-level grave marker
issued by the federal government
via the National Cemetery Administration.
It's a white marble
material, natural stone.
He was a gunner's mate,
GM, third class, US Navy.
I don't think it's respectful to have
a veteran's headstone dirty in the least.
And so we're going to clean this headstone
of this American hero who gave his all,
who sacrificed unimaginable horrors
for three and a half years
as a prisoner of war.
The first thing I like to do is
I use a desk broom
to get all of the sand and
debris off of the stone.
So, we take our water-squirt bottle.
I like the one with a little
bit bigger base on it.
I give it a coating of water,
because, again, these stones are porous,
so it's going to soak in this clean water,
which is not going to get
any chemical down inside the stone.
We use a cleaning agent that
contains an active ingredient
known as a quaternary ammonium compound.
And it is known and respected
throughout historic
preservationists as the safest,
most effective way to clean natural stone.
This brush is made with
bristles from Tampico.
So the Tampico from the agave
plant is a natural bristle
that won't harm the natural stone.
And then I want to give it a good coating
of the D/2 Biological Solution,
which is going to go to work
on this stone very quickly.
You're going to see this stone
starting to turn a bit of an orange color.
And then it's going to
continue working on the stone
for the next few weeks,
and that stone will become
brighter and whiter and whiter.
And you have to clean them
about every two to three years.
This does a wonderful job
of getting all the growth
killed on the stone.
The next step is to let that
soak for about 10 minutes.
When I'm looking at a
headstone in a cemetery,
I want that stone to be impeccably clean.
It doesn't matter if it's almost clean.
It needs to be clean.
I think the reason why
some veteran headstones
become more soiled or more
covered in biological growth
is because of the polishing of the stone.
The more polished the stone,
the less surface area there is
for the biological organisms
to adhere to the stone.
And after about 10 minutes,
it's not that hard to get
the material off the stone
with a soft-bristle,
natural-bristle brush.
Then you can get into the
etchings with a toothbrush
to get into the real nooks and
crannies of things sometimes.
And the final step of
honoring a veteran of our past
is to place an American
flag at their grave.
This is known as a grave flag.
This particular grave has already had
an American Legion flag
holder placed at the grave,
and there's a spot in the back of them
for the flag stick to just
stick right down into it.
My vision of By Memorial Day is that
one day in the near future,
we'll have a volunteer
assigned to every
veteran's grave in America,
no matter where that veteran is buried,
no matter what cemetery they're in.
So, to tell you a little
bit about why this happens,
these are living organisms.
These are plants growing on the stone,
whether they're algae or lichens
or mold, mildew.
And so the reason why we use this
quaternary ammonium
compound is this kills them.
So these things are natural in nature.
You're going to find in
the South especially,
we have this black mold on all of our
concrete-tile roofs.
And it's not just growing on rooftops;
it's also growing on our headstones.
I think it's important that
we don't lose the stories
of our veteran heroes of the past,
because they truly are forgotten.
Their stories are disappearing
because when they pass away
and the people who knew them pass away,
their stories are pretty
much gone forever.
So, now we're going to
start on the etchings.
I start with the cross at the top
and work my way down just each letter.
These are etched into the marble.
As compared to the
early veteran headstones
known as bas-relief, where the letters
were basically sticking out,
they removed the material
around the letters.
So the letters became
kind of three-dimensional.
The material that grows
inside these stones,
it's a combination of
things fixed in there,
and also there's little
ledges, so to speak,
where when the wind
blows, the pollen falls,
all different types of
things will just get wedged
and just build up in these etchings.
Grave flags measure 8 inches by 12 inches,
but I would rather have
a flag than no flag,
so if you can't find an 8-by-12,
that doesn't mean you can't
place a flag at the grave.
The person at a podium
speaking, for example,
the American flag is to their right.
So in this case, we have a
headstone of an American veteran.
So as the veteran's looking at you,
the flag needs to be to his or her right.
You want to get as close
to the stone as you can
without marring the
stone with your mallet.
Because when the weed eaters
and other types of maintenance
equipment comes through,
you don't want them
hitting your flag holder.
The way that I research the veterans
buried beneath the veteran
headstones that I clean
is by using the internet first.
And I go to certain sources
that I know contain content,
such as findagrave.com.
There's several different
websites like that.
And by looking into
those different databases
and different family
trees on ancestry.com,
you can start to put together
the story of a veteran.
And every now and then you just
get something that's amazing
and insightful that you didn't anticipate.
This is a application
for a headstone or marker
for a deceased American veteran.
The family members would have
to complete this application
in order to choose what
style of veteran headstone
that they wanted for their loved one.
And this particular application is for
Robert S. Lewis,
prepared by his father.
And this is where the
story of his sacrifice
became apparent.
This man was a sergeant.
Sgt. Shadman was a top turret gunner.
"Fire in the cockpit. Could
not see if he got out.
I saw Sgt. Shadman
reaching for a parachute.
I do not believe he could
have gotten out alive
because the plane broke apart
where he was last seen."
When they were attacked, they
were flying at 24,000 feet.
Sgt. Shadman was up in the
top turret, he was a gunner,
and he was trying to get
out of that top turret
as the plane was tumbling to the ground.
His death's date says September 12, 1944.
But there's evidence to
suggest that he did in fact
get out of that aircraft and
he did reach the ground alive
because there's a hospital
admission record of him
in September 1944.
We don't know what day that he died,
but his mother applied
for his veteran headstone
with a death date of September 23rd.
In your local cemeteries,
there are local heroes
whose graves are in really bad condition,
and it's pretty sad that a man or a woman
gives their life for our country
and then they're forgotten in the cemetery
and their headstone can't even be read
because there's so much
biological filth on it.
There are people in America who
care about veterans' graves,
they just don't know
what's happening out here.
So I want to bring this story to them
so that they know that
in your local cemeteries,
there are local heroes whose graves
are in really bad condition.
So if this is something
that speaks to your heart,
I encourage you to get out
in your local cemetery,
see for yourself if
there's veteran headstones
in need of cleaning in your local area,
and take the initiative
to do something about it.
Narrator: This is a rare
Persian rug that's appraised
at an estimated $12,500,
and it's about to get its first cleaning
in more than two decades.
It's a delicate job,
and not just because this
antique is so valuable.
It's also a family heirloom,
and the clients are trusting
the team at Rouzati Rugs
to deep clean it carefully.
The goal is to remove the accumulation
of dirt and stains without
harming the rug's coloring.
Ali Rouzati inspects the fibers carefully
to determine how the
rug was originally dyed.
This key detail will determine
how he'll complete the job
without causing any damage,
so his clients can continue to pass down
this treasure for generations.
Ali: So, my client's aunt had
this rug for about 20 years,
and she was very hesitant
to have it cleaned
because she was afraid
that it would get ruined.
I know this is a 1940s rug
because they used vegetable dyes,
in comparison to a 1960s
Tabriz, like this one here.
There's a specific process to
cleaning vegetable-dye rugs.
I know that I can use a deep wash
because the dyes won't run.
This is the pool that we
have the rugs cleaned,
and we have a drain right here.
It's built on an angle
so that when we put a rug on either side,
the water will just go right through
directly into the drain.
Narrator: One of Ali's team members
begins the cleaning process
by applying browning
treatment to the stains.
This works to remove tannin-type stains
like urine, fruit juice, beer, or soil
as well as general
discoloration due to age.
This 1940s Sheikh Mashayekhi
rug has collected stains
from various family gatherings
throughout the years,
but that's not all that
makes this Tabriz rug unique.
What makes it so special is
not only the technique of weave
and the fine weaving on the back,
but also the design
and the color combinations
that are used as well.
Narrator: After letting
the browning treatment
sit for 15 minutes,
he hoses down the rug and applies shampoo.
Next, he agitates the
fibers with a scrubber,
which loosens up the accumulated dirt
and brings it to the surface.
Ali: So, the scrubber or the buffer
is used to help scrub
and expand the use of the
shampoo throughout the rug,
and it does it in a
fast and efficient way.
So if you were to actually hand-do this,
not only would you get tired physically,
but it wouldn't be as effective.
Narrator: Ali estimates
that the original weaver
made only a few hundred
of these rugs decades ago.
The coloring also dates back to a time
when master weavers used
different techniques.
This rug is made with vegetable-dyed wool,
which means the coloring
came from natural materials
like plants, fruits, or tree bark.
This method is more labor-intensive,
which adds to the rug's value.
Ali: Chrome dyes come from chemicals
that are used and boiled
to create certain colors.
Chrome dyes were used to decrease the cost
of rug weaving.
So in terms of price point,
they are less in comparison to rugs
that have vegetable dyes
incorporated in them.
As you can see, this type
of a red tone is so bright.
You only see that in chrome dyes.
But with vegetable dyes,
they're a little bit more
subtle in comparison.
Narrator: The transition
from vegetable dyes
to chrome dyes in the mid-20th century
brought about a new era in rug making.
Chrome dyes offered a wider
and more affordable range of hues,
which revolutionized the industry.
But the legacy of those
early Persian rug makers
is still visible today in rugs like this,
which is why it's so
important to preserve it.
The team member rinses the
rug and pushes a squeegee
across each section to
remove excess water.
He repeats this step several times
throughout the cleaning process
to remove as much water as possible.
He runs the scrubber across the rug again
to loosen any remaining dirt
and then uses the extractor
to lift the stains
and remove moisture.
Ali: The extractor
actually has two purposes.
You can, one, just use it as a vacuum.
You just place it on the rug,
and you start pulling it
towards your direction,
and it starts extracting the water out
so that the rug gets to dry faster.
Also, it has another feature
where if you press on the lever,
not only will it extract water,
but it'll expel hot
water at the same time.
And those are great for taking away stains
because you could do that
multiple times on a certain area.
All the rugs are heated
to a high temperature
of I'd say about 90 degrees on average,
and they're hung right here.
Narrator: The rug must be completely dry
before moving on to the next step.
If not, the excess moisture
can lead to mold and mildew,
two factors that can deteriorate
the fibers in the rug.
Ali: We'll go inside of the drying room,
and we'll examine it and
touch the pile of the rug,
the fringes, and the
other aspects of the rug
to see if it's still moist or not.
If we feel it is, we'll keep it in there.
The room is dry to a
very high temperature,
and just having all the
fans and dehumidifiers,
usually having a rug in
there for about a day
would completely dry it out.
Narrator: The quality
of weave on Tabriz rugs
is based on something called raj,
which counts the number of
linear knots every 7 centimeters,
which is roughly 2 ½ inches.
The higher the raj,
the higher the quality,
which also makes a rug more valuable.
So, in today's market,
I would estimate this
value around $12,500.
You have these lines that are showing
on the backside of the rug,
and when you look at those lines,
you'll be able to actually count
how many knots are in between each line.
And so this specific rug is 50 raj.
On a lower-quality Tabriz,
you'll have a 20 raj.
This is actually a lower-quality Tabriz.
You can see how big the knots are
in comparison to this rug here.
These knots are a lot more tight.
This is around that 20 raj
that I had mentioned earlier.
And then you have the 50 raj,
which is a more higher quality.
60 raj would be very exceptional.
And then you'll have 80 or 90 raj,
which are extremely rare to find,
and those type of rugs take
close to 10 years to make.
But this type of a caliber,
I'd say in terms of rarity,
on a scale of one to 10,
it would be a seven.
So, when you look at the
different color combinations
and designs that are used in this rug,
it seems like there's a lot of
religious symbolism going on,
and that makes sense
because Sheikh Mashayekhi
was a religious man within his region.
And the predominant use of green
is of Islamic religious significance
because green was the prophet
Muhammad's favorite color.
I've grown up with
Persian rugs in my home,
and there's a lot of deep
cultural significance
to Persian rugs and the history behind it.
So I feel very akin to my culture
being in this industry.
The rug looks magnificent.
It's much brighter than it was before,
and the majority of the
stains have been removed.
There are a lot of other
people in this industry
that really don't put their heart into it.
They just clock in and clock out.
But each rug is
a portion of a person's home,
and I take that responsibility to heart,
that when they bring their rug to me
they're bringing a part
of their home into my life
for me to take care of.